[Applause]
what first of all what are your personal
opinions on like the celebrity ceo
specifically musk i think it's better
that we have celebrity ceos than
celebrity celebrities
like it's like saying what do you think
about these green smoothies well were we
gonna just have like
milkshakes instead then it's probably a
health improvement even if
eating nothing but green smoothies
probably isn't good for you you're
saying like
you'd rather somebody be famous for
doing something great
then just be famous for the sake of
being famous so musk over kardashian
well i mean is there any debate like it
depends what you need you need an
electric car do you need to
uh evacuate your testicles
[Laughter]
that's why people buy those electric
cars i'll send something on mars
no it's like look if we're going to tilt
it might back over
the celebrity ceo is not new we've had a
lot of them i mean
rockefeller jp morgan i mean those guys
the robber barons were probably all
celebrities at the time
well look at some of the antics that uh
like
tesla and uh what's his name
uh edison sort of some of their sort of
oh nicola
yeah oh okay the original tesla if you
look at some of their sort of battles
it's kind of interesting i think edison
electrocuted an elephant
as like a public display to prove that
uh he had the best tesla
i think that's how it went it was
something like that so one
none of this stuff is new yeah uh the
idea of sort of a
a prominent ceo i mean howard hughes i
guess was kind of
yeah was elon musk before elon musk and
it worked out well
well no he ended up peeing in jars
so so look it's like uh
okay so so go and we're back so in a
nutshell
famous smart people probably better than
famous dumb people
i'm i'm cool with that as a general
thing i i've been
i wasn't asking more of like from an
ethical standard i i meant
as a tool for the business is it a
useful tool
or are you putting too much liability on
the company on
your actions as a person it's both right
like if you look at uh
i was having a debate with one of my
business partners that we also share
some
uh investment initiatives with adam and
we were talking about sort of investing
yeah
in tesla versus amazon at the beginning
of the pandemic
and he was sort of following a lot of
the kind of kathy woods uh
mentality and was really bullish on
tesla
and i'm like i really respect what
they've done i think what they've done
is incredible
but i find that i feel safer with my
money
with someone like bezos that seems more
methodical a little bit more measured
i think elon musk is a singular
brilliant genius
but with any genius there's no such
thing as a bulletproof genius that hits
to all fields there's
he's not like a five to a player he's
asymmetrically talented
in this sort of area but he's still
gonna
be a flawed individual as anyone else
and when so much of the corporate
identity
is tied up to him and so much of the
stock price is tied to retail investors
are sort of evangelizing
we're a truly great person but perhaps
not really seeing that
there is no such thing as an individual
entity in business
it's all teamwork it's all collaboration
there's thousands of employees there's
thousands of engineers all working
together and he's a fantastic leader
yeah but it is a it's it's something
that would show up
i think in the the stock price that if
like if he dies if something happens to
him and that's game over
yeah that is so interesting and yeah
that's what it's not well diversified in
terms of its leadership yeah that's what
i was trying to get out with the
question right is
is when you evangelize a ceo
you can probably take the company higher
than
if you really promote or exalt the
company itself
right because we can look at one person
as almost for lack of a better word a
god
right but we don't really look at
companies like that we think they're
really cool
but we're not going oh my god you have
superhuman powers
and superhuman powers can take you up
there but they can also take you way
down
the second kanye leaves yeezy i don't
know if it has any value
right right because we're really
investing what about steve jobs
so so here's a perfect example jobs
right like
jobs was this person that like kind of
became
a superhero late in his career earlier
in his career they bounced his ass out
of the company
right like i feel like we almost have a
revisionist history with jobs
because he wasn't initially when we
i mean i had one of those first uh what
i think i was a macintosh
i had one of them as a kid right and
like i never was like oh steve jobs is
the man
right i just thought that the company
was really cool macintosh
the apple the thing was all bitten out
of it was cool the branding was great
so i guess what i'm wondering you can
even see it with um
dave portnoy right the company spend
poor noise porn comes out
spend dips five percent on the stock
market i think it was five or ten or
something like that right stuff or
something like that
so you you when you are tied to the
stock price when the personality and the
actions of that person are tied to the
stock price there's immense pressure
to live life a certain way and make all
those decisions because you know your
personal decisions can affect the
company
as brilliant as jeff bezos is i don't
know if the average person is going
jeff bezos is smarter than eli i think
we have a
do you think the average person thinks
that bazel is smarter than elon or is he
like no he just figured out how to put
things in boxes good
i think the average person confuses
company leadership with the idea of
inventing uh
people think that elon invented things
when really he's leading a
complex team through a scientific and
engineering process
to make innovation at scale in these new
markets
yeah and that's sorry that's just
leadership vision and coordination not
like
i figured out the special formula of
mixing this with this
to be fair to elon he is also capable
as an engineer right right whereas
bezos is not an engineer so he's not
going to be working on the rockets
for blue horizon right right he'll be an
amazing leader and get the people who
will build those rockets and know how to
manage them and get the most out of them
but when push comes to shove from what
i've read
is sometimes elon will get in there
right get down with the nitty-gritty
because that is his background
right but they're also they're i think
what they're really getting rewarded for
is their ability to play this complex
chess game of deploying capital
and resources towards non-linear
processes that are unpredictable
right and that's what sort of research
is an example of a non-linear process
that's unpredictable
uh the development of like figuring out
the best way to make an electric car if
there aren't a lot of electric cars
already and the previous ones were very
unsatisfactory from a customer
standpoint
they have a bunch of hypothesis that
they're going to test yeah but no one's
manufactured those at scale
so a linear process is it's like a
recipe here's how to make chocolate chip
cookies
give me chocolate chips give me flour
sugar
boom right you know all you know all the
variables it's just like you doing it
and you're going to get better at it
over time so
non-linear is we know how they did it
before that might not be the best way
let's find a new way to create the
recipe for this
and i know how much capital that we need
to deploy in order to do that right
i know the people that we need to hire
etc right and when you have
too many unknown variables you have to
kind of like make working hypothesis you
can't predict it all
you have to kind of guess on this and
then watch the results track that
learn from that mistake apply it to a
different thing try something else
and it's sort of experiment in advance
so i think that's what's really good
about them is like i don't think
they have like this perfect road map
from when they started amazon or tesla
and this is where we're going
what they had to sort of see was to
learn on the fly keep deploying capital
keep impressing investors to keep more
capital coming in
and then keep sort of managing that
relative to the increasing amount of
competition they have on all fronts
uh both of these companies have taken on
all comers i mean remember that
that company like jet or something like
that that was like we're going to
compete with amazon
and then nothing or it's like now
there's like every
car company says we're going to make
electric cars and stuff like that so
i think there there's it's not the
genius of sort of like i figured out
this product i'm an inventor
and then i translate into a entrepreneur
yeah
i think it's really this game of
strategically seeing the whole
field and industry and deploying
resources appropriately
but the stock price goes up when we
think he's a great inventor
yeah like literally we're at least
three the four of us in this room
meaning everyone except you has invented
uh invested in tesla because we think
elon's the best inventor
not because he's good at what is it
non-linear capital deployment
i i i you know what i'm saying i've been
invested i'm being honest i'm like that
[ __ ] just made an electric car
really good he's probably gonna make a
spaceship even better
he's gonna go to mars okay take a few
thousand dollars elon that's literally
my thinking with tesla
i i invested in tesla even though i
thought it was overpriced
simply because i had fomo and so many of
my close friends were heavily invested
in tesla yeah and i wouldn't feel
comfortable
with them being significantly wealthier
than me yeah yeah yeah i feel you that's
the only reason why i have crypto yeah
it's like this it's [ __ ] akash it's
it's
so much money when it all goes to the
bottom the fomo investment strategy yeah
yeah
one of my close friends that's invested
in some of my real estate projects he
invests in
all of our friends from colleges
startups yeah strictly because
he just couldn't live with himself if
one of his friends like
yes he blew right past him i'd rather
lose a hundred thousand dollars than
be poorer than my absolutely
because it makes it awkward it really
does
it makes it awkward you know what's not
awkward when they're bored of me not
awkward at all
or for all four together that's great
that's how we started
best time of our life there's like the
three musketeers all for one one for all
yeah all at the bottom
okay fair enough so it does make it so
it is a little trickier and maybe
elon is misunderstood but he understands
that him being misunderstood is
advantageous
yeah i think the thing that's really
interesting is what he kind of is
doing jokingly with like dogecoin and
tweeting about it and just like driving
these
what's his thing with dogecoin first of
all are you familiar with dogecoin
and what it is uh i took an edible one
night
i saw some really cute doggy memes i'm
kind of partial to animal videos and
memes in general yeah and so i went on
robin hood and i think about like
maybe like two to three grand no like
just kind of like
dabbled yeah i bought it like just under
one cent uh a coin
okay and then i immediately texted my
buddy norbert shout out to norbert
um and i was like hey i bought some
dogecoin you went in he's like
[ __ ] and so of course he has to buy some
because again doesn't want anyone to get
ahead of him yeah
and it sort of went up to like four
cents we hedged our bet
sold off like our initial sort of uh
stake and then sort of watching now it's
like at 40 cents
yeah stuff like that but my thought was
just like i was looking at
it was trending on twitter for like
days and days in a row yeah and when i
look at like if
if you were to spend money you know
you'll see like oh this new movie
without remorse starring michael b
jordan is like
you know the promoted trending thing on
twitter yeah i'm like that's probably
really expensive i don't know exactly
how much it costs to put yourself on the
trending page for a media campaign yeah
but it's it's got to be probably low six
figures
high five figures at the very least
assume it is sure
so if dogecoin was getting that kind of
media value
organically every day regardless of what
you think of the asset
i know something about sort of media
pricing and exposure
and i'm like they're organically
generating a lot
of views so if i'm buying that at one
sense and they're
consistently getting this much view okay
i'm only investing in that sort of
phenomena
not in any fundamentals so let's digest
it right so so basically you're saying
if it wasn't dogecoin if it was an
advertising for
underwear or something like that and
they were gonna yield like one percent
return
on the the trending not trending
aperture or on their advertisements
right or let's say that
one five percent of the people that saw
their advertisement up on twitter we're
gonna go buy the underwear
you can apply the same thing to dogecoin
trending organically
right you can be a viable business with
just
one advantage and if you have like three
or four that stack and play well with
each other you can be a juggernaut
yeah so if somebody and this is why sort
of like influencer created products are
kind of interesting
yeah that if they speak to the audience
demographic of that influencer
and they're cost neutral yeah and that
person has unlimited inventory to
publicize it to a pretty good sized
audience
they're going to have a competitive
advantage now they might not be able to
scale
and you know they might be limited at
like a 300 000 a year in sales kind of
company yeah yeah
but they have an advantage from zero to
[Applause]
something
you